I have to say though as great as JK as
the audience is because really you guys
are the best
think Casey neistat's audience a little
bit better
[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys don't move
look how cute
so cute CUNY wow which one's the cute
one
oh thanks guys
well uh for this off the Record what we
wanted to chat about per Ryan's
suggestion was who have you blocked on
social media oh that's a good question
Colleen I just I just blocked Ryan how
you
doing I got to you first dude
I block a lot of uh trolls or fake
accounts that just want to harass uh my
fans in the comments yeah that happens a
lot you give harass a lot in the
comments the like Instagram or whatever
like they might argue with other people
my comment or like just whatever like
they make up unpleasant experience for
our actual supporters they kill the vibe
yeah that makes sense yeah then for me
it's just like better to not have that
around you know do you feel like you're
inciting the violence how well I don't
know I'm like why it's a question
I'm a [ __ ] inside violence I am
violence oh [ __ ] that's tight it's
really cool I mean that's like something
Judge Dredd would say yeah dude and then
he blasts all the all the criminals
Batman I posted recently on my story
someone that uh messaged me I think they
messaged me through the like knowing
that I was on the JK account that day I
saw that and they were talking to me and
they were like hey can you unblock me I
was like they were like you blocked me
when I was 10. yeah you deserved it you
little [ __ ] that was like that's so
funny the fact that this person
remembers yeah it's like almost a decade
ago they were like they were like all I
asked was how come he only post car
pictures and then you commented and said
how come you're blocked and then I was
blocked
do you block people for fun that's so
funny and then I was like oh [ __ ] I
remember that
so I unblocked them I bet that made you
laugh though it did it did because it's
so stupid yeah because I thought it was
just like a dumb thing you know what my
favorite
you guys probably get this dm2 but have
you ever had someone DM you and say hey
can you tell like BART to stop blocking
me or Dave oh yeah yeah yeah yeah as
soon as they say that [ __ ] they get
blocked I blocked well that's because
they're good judge they're good judge I
trust Bart and David more than I trust
you you [ __ ] stranger
why would I fight on your behalf and
tell my close friend hey man there's
this [ __ ] stranger that you blocked
he's a good guy man think you should
unblock that this is a good person give
a second chance man it was his birthday
he was a little bit drunk he was only
10. he didn't mean it there was a very
strange situation I ran into where like
um I had this friend who runs this like
nightclub and he was like yo I got a
great live band at my club you should
come by with the guys and just and dance
like it's really fun I was like all
right let me check it out and he goes uh
yeah let me send you some info and then
he sent me the band leader it's like a
funk band he's like oh here's the band
leader like uh he's excited to meet you
and I was like I can't see his page and
then I realized I blocked this family
and I don't know why so then I told my
friend I'm like hey this is gonna sound
weird
but I can't go because I must hate this
guy I just don't know why I don't like
them or you're like so I have to confess
something ten years ago I was posting a
lot of carpets
like a lot of garbage and this
[ __ ]
audacity
and then saxophone Joe just added too
much of a problem with it yeah why don't
you pull some [ __ ] regular daily
picks and [ __ ] wait so if you block
someone you can't look at their stuff no
because I I went to his profile and it
was just like black but it said but then
it said unblock yeah and I was like oh
what the [ __ ] and then I was like bro
like I wish I knew why I did this I have
no clue well you just randomly block
people no I don't I only block people
but they're like if they said something
like that I you know was like oh that
you can't be saying that [ __ ] or
something or if it's a bad day but this
dude is like or if it's like hey how can
you put something
yeah I think that was just like me being
petty that's so funny this guy like he's
like a established musician I'm like why
would this guy why would he have a
problem he's probably an [ __ ] I love
this guy refresh his feet she's another
our picture
the [ __ ] is with this guy and he's 10
years old
he's like another Acura Type R
[Laughter]
really wait how many years has a gap
before this person I think it was like a
decade
yeah wow it was something like that it
was forever that's what it gets after
you unblock him the next comment you
just block them again
um that's what everybody's saying about
it and what about when someone blocks
you
um how would you know how do you know
that
do you see there you try to search for
this page and you don't know yeah like
from that guy's perspective that you
blocked like is he just well he said
that like uh that he saw that I was on
JK and was like oh cool he's on JK now
and then clicked my name on the things
and was like oh I'm blocked
it wasn't something that he like
remembered for 12 years like every
morning I think he knew because I
because I said why are you blocked and
then blocked them so that's a funny
exchange as a 10 year old then he didn't
think he was like I think he forgot that
he was still blocked and then he like
clicked my name after JK stuff and was
like my God yeah have you noticed if
you've ever been blocked by someone
because I never been on anyone's pages I
don't know how yeah I guess it depends
like if something like I don't know if
you have a falling out with a person in
real life and that's the only time you'd
really care to change that's right I've
unfollowed I wouldn't have blocks though
well it's nice that you can restrict now
what is the recession so it's like it's
basically like a block but they don't
know they're blocked oh that's tight you
can also mute and that it's the person
that you would restricted can see
comments or interact that's good because
sometimes you just don't want to deal
with it it's like I'm gonna unfollow you
and then like three months from now
you're like why'd you unfollow me it's
like I don't [ __ ] even remember I
just don't like you you could just mute
you can mute well back when you guys
like have relationships and it didn't
work out did you block or unfriend on
MySpace or some [ __ ] like the person you
were dating you would first change your
status your relationship to no longer
you know like Dude That's Heavy you
remember that
like the next 10 people that you'd
hopefully have a relationship with once
you click save and it says I'm single
and you click save you
wow there it is
my life is different my life is
different and then people can comment on
it I remember that the pain of like
breaking up and then seeing that you
were removed from their like top eight
yo being removed from a MySpace topic
was like a [ __ ] yeah as a huge [ __ ] you
also big time early warning sign that
maybe your relationship isn't going so
good you start popping down in the top
eight like they start moving you moving
you down flushing you down a little bit
yeah that was a scary time for
vulnerable youth first would be like a
sibling you're like okay I can
understand that and it's like a cousin
and you're like oh oh all right so you
told me you didn't even like this
because yeah what the [ __ ] and then it's
another friend here it's a second cousin
it's like oh they could actually [ __ ]
and it's actually legal so you're losing
your rankings that's your thought
process and then it's your best friend
then you're like wait what what the [ __ ]
yeah yeah that didn't happen to me
either cruel dude when's the last time
you guys signed into your Facebook bro I
can't even get in there every time I try
to deactivate it and I forget the
password of life it's like it's like
Bally's yeah yeah what was I trying to
do again they did this [ __ ] it years
ago where like you can't
um if you you know I was people were
trying to sign into this meal all the
time or whatever and so I I got blocked
out and they're like you need to unlock
your account by having one of your
friends say that it's you and so I need
to do that with two people one of them
was my grandmother who doesn't use
Facebook at all she just has a Facebook
account and then the second person was
some random [ __ ] person that I added
because I was just like we're not in my
early early YouTube days when I had like
10 000 subscribers I was just adding
people on Facebook because I was like
sure I don't care who gives a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] and then it's just
some random kid like some random like
Mexican dude like like probably 12 years
13 years old when I when he followed me
is now like a full grown man and like he
I don't think he even remembers any of
that [ __ ] so I'm like I gotta ask this
guy like hey it's really me yeah I'm
just like [ __ ] this [ __ ] you Facebook
I'm not touching it that's Facebook dude
you know what's a weird thing that
happened to me not too long ago I was at
uh this club and I ran into this guy and
he's like Ryan and I was like yeah
what's up he's like dude I used to
[ __ ] hate you man
oh cool man that's right well yeah
because he said that like on um on zanga
or like
bro let things go my boy pre Myspace
days he he like he had a crush on his
girl
that he also didn't know but like we I
guess we both followed her blog and then
he said that like that he thought she
liked me so he was like hated me and he
would just hate watch all my stuff and
hate watch my ABDC all throughout my
whole career he's like oh [ __ ] that guy
yeah he followed you on every social
platform to hate watch and I was like
what girl are you talking about and he
goes oh it's this girl like and then he
told me and I was like bro I don't even
[ __ ] Know Her Like She's you just
created this whole scenario are you
[ __ ] serious he's like I hated you
for like 12 years
Dan you should have looked and be like
bro dude I smashed the [ __ ] yeah and
then I put her in the garbage
she mentioned she liked you too but then
[ __ ] it yeah I was like I bet you this
guy he hate watched you and spent so
much time with you but he didn't even
talk to the girl yeah I don't think he
ever did dude the idea of watching you
the idea of watching you kill it on ABDC
but being like
this is so funny to me but the idea of
watching you killing ABDC but like week
after week after week after a week until
you win come on get eliminated he's like
voting against me and [ __ ] oh I can't
wait they need [ __ ] watches oh I hate
you yeah sounds like a tough challenge I
don't think he never got to see you lose
you won but it's like over that it's
like crazy
that [ __ ] though at that point in life
was very important to us adolescents you
know so I can understand how that like
[ __ ] lives really rent-free in a huge
part of your brain you know yeah I mean
that's a hell of a crazy thing to assume
like just because we both have her like
on our followed blogs
hate watch not even I used to do it all
the [ __ ] like how does that work how
does it work I don't even know how to
process hate watching so
um okay perfect example there's um a
certain person on Instagram that Bart
put me on to who's like Miss
inspirational every [ __ ] day let me
teach you about business and let me
teach you about inspiration
about inspiration I [ __ ] laugh my ass
off at every single post oh that one
yeah yeah yeah and she's always like
like mid like hoping your business and
marketing is really just about personal
uh personal ability and like like
friendship and like building trustful
relationships with your clients and I'm
like oh my God this is the most generic
[ __ ] like she thinks the fact that she
thinks that this is like next level [ __ ]
is why it's so [ __ ] hilarious to us
does she actually have like an example
of of finding success using these or
she's just talking about the Mantra of
it I don't know I think she's a face to
make it person it's pretty uh like what
everyone else says it's like the most
generic [ __ ] ever but without examples
of like it's like [ __ ] that you put on
wood and like put your mom has on her
wall it's like it's like actually a live
laugh live laugh love lift it's very uh
inspirational quotes meme page it almost
sounds like one of those Dr lesby and
twitters oh those are great those are
great but no yeah um
so yeah I hate watching I I hate I hate
I hate also that is that a haywatch but
you're just laughing you're not affected
right because the way have you hate
watching is like you actually don't like
the person hate them so you study them I
don't know her there are some people
that you like cringe when you watch but
you can't look away because it's like
you know like car accident it's like oh
like this like I I follow a couple
people that do Post like that they do
like food stuff
and then sometimes you just can't like
for a while like mukbangs I would watch
mukbangs I was like I hate watch because
I couldn't stand it but I just couldn't
stop watching it and now I love it and
I'm a fan yeah I think that's different
I wouldn't even call that hate watch
though because I feel like that's such a
um that's always too sad like there's uh
it's like watching a a dancer that I
know that I don't really like them as a
person but my man this guy's [ __ ]
talented
you know what I'm saying so it's like
it's different there's also like clearly
a joy or some sort of inspiration I do
remember
um before they had the muting feature or
restrictions I did uh for a moment
unfollow one of one of my uh one of my
crewmates because he's annoying but I
said this I specifically mentioned this
in a GroupMe or on social media I was
like I love y'all but if you're just
only put if like 90 of your posts are
Selfies I'm not gonna follow you oh
really yeah damn is it is it a male yeah
no I crack I'll crack up with him all
the time about it but still dude you
post selfies I can't handle it I can't
[ __ ] handle it I like it when their
whole Thief is the same selfie with
different backgrounds yeah yeah even
girls too bro because at a while after a
while you're like if this person might
be crazy that's what I think yeah when
it's too many of their faces and it's
just like yeah
they're like Jesus all selfies it just
feels it feels like a beautiful girl
posting herself I can handle it yeah I'm
not real I'm not a little [ __ ]
okay Steve I [ __ ] hate it all right
it's like I hate jack off right after do
you guys care if someone hates you no if
I did I don't know how I would even
stand up it's on the relationship prior
right yeah if there was a relationship
yeah you don't wanna
yeah because you don't want to feel hate
from someone you love that hurts yeah
it's like you care about them but then
just like a random person yeah I mean
we're in entertainment we're we're we
have an audience like there's people
that's gonna have judgment and all that
and there's people that are absolutely
like in love with you and there's also
people that just [ __ ] hate you I
would say initially I don't care but
initially I am curious and when I'm
curious I want to find out and if I find
out I might care yeah yeah yeah like
their opinion just why like like if
they're like oh I hate you because this
then I'm like oh [ __ ] I might care about
that you know what I mean but if it's
like somebody just randomly hates me I
don't care but I'm like
I'm curious I think it's really cool
like one of my favorite things is is how
the audience or the community around JK
changed so much and how like now when
you look at there'll be like some
[ __ ] serial hate Watchers in the
comments that are like you look at all
the comments they've ever made and it's
like 10 weeks in a row of dead Channel
channels dying Channel's dead but then
now we're growing and growing and
growing
but there's like always people like uh
but we're still dead I think like
Melanie's one of them and like they're
always in the comments under those going
like why are you still here dude yeah
it's sad it's pretty sad I love the
defense of like the JK people now that
they're so quick to to just be like dude
just go
you know what I mean because I don't
think it was like that in the old
right it was just
comments yeah it was like that was like
the only way to get attention to your
comment using comments right I think
like that era with um a lot of channels
drama channels they kind of came out and
then like people started liking that and
then like a lot of uh fake YouTube stuff
like [ __ ] with their fans you know
like then you start to scrutinize all of
creators because of some people that
were just constructing like a honorable
life on camera but then in reality like
behind the scenes and we all we all know
that there's so many people that do that
[ __ ] they're like oh we have the perfect
[ __ ] marriage all of them yeah and
we've we know who they are but then it's
like also it's like yeah but oh I would
hate watch that I would hate watch that
for sure yeah but then you know but then
the audience do you know how like I'd
imagine how much they feel duped if
they've been following them for a long
time and then they go like oh what the
[ __ ] they're not the people who I
thought they were well there's a
cognitive dissonance there too even when
it gets revealed like hey this perfect
family is not that there's people still
sticking up for it in the comments being
like that's true no like we don't know
like it's like they're literally saying
we hate each other yeah the truth is we
just [ __ ] hate each other and then
there's people just like oh no but like
I don't know
I don't know it's like boy but I think
after all that like no no YouTuber was
like a saint so then they they they
treat everybody like I I guess like
maybe the critics would treat everybody
as if they're like money grab grubbing
like weirdos you know yeah yeah but I
don't know I think that's just comes
with the territory of having an audience
you're gonna have people who love you
people who hate you people who pass
judgment I have to say though as great
as JK his audience is because really you
guys are the best
think Casey neistat's audience a little
bit better
and all I mean by that is if you go to
Casey neistat's comments
it's not just people love his videos but
they're like and I love your [ __ ] ads
your AdWords are so goddamn good your
eyes are so creative and good I'm like
man that is like wow even I love your
ads tip of the cap to Casey but when you
watch his ads do you feel like he went
above and beyond than other people his
ads are pretty sick though
we just got words you know what he does
dude this guy like if I could edit and
[ __ ] film like him come on today's
video is brought to you by tushy
and Bart's like
tushy's great because like yeah you know
because like yeah you can smile dude
Bart salesman Smiles [ __ ] crazy
wouldn't there be an ad read like
moments ago in this video yep and
whatever it was buy it yeah yeah please
please comment that you loved the ad
read today in this video it helps us get
our pay reduced by forty percent
we should start doing that randomly
throughout the video just being like
and welcome back hey whatever that
product was make sure you purchase it I
got a DM the other day uh a fan was like
oh damn congratulations you guys got
like 200 000 more subs does that mean
that everyone's not gonna have their 40
reduced anymore and I'm all like subs
don't make us money
it was like we're all we're building a
fire I'm like
adding little buckles and sticks
[Applause]
and then we just see go yeah
it starts raining everybody on our heads
yeah just one thunder cloud right here
yep
audible why
how could you
you need more views please we should do
that it's a 10 minute Mark someone just
got done watching an ad yeah yeah you're
still with us purchase that product yeah
and this channel is dead
[Music]
foreign